You guys have caught me,
literally,
last moment off
of the last scene on set.
I can't really process it yet.
Do you want to,
let's take a last look with me?
All right, we're going to go in
for the last time.
Okay.
Let's go.
Bittersweet.
Okay.
Let's do it.
Oh my God, this is really sad.
This is me, this is my artwork
from college.
Like real artwork
but they, it's a print.
You guys like scanned it-
Yeah.
... and there's another one
of these in my bedroom.
Yeah 'cause originally we had
some of your actual things.
Oh my gosh yeah.
The markers was like yours.
Oh yes.
Yes.
When we borrowed it.
When we get in there
my bedroom is like so mine.
-Yeah.
In the hurricane episode
there's like this little
close up of these little dudes
having their moment.
You know this story.
This is unbelievable.
I bought a rug, okay,
in my personal living room
and I was like,
"Guys I really want Abbi
to have a new rug."
And like just a couple
new things to be like,
"Oh she's like older now."
I try to differentiate myself
from the character
and I come in here
and I was like,
"That's my fucking carpet."
Of all the rugs in all the world
they bought
the same carpet as me.
Yeah.
It makes me almost upset
because I'm like,
"I'm her. I'm just her."
This is my brother and my dad in
real life at the Grand Canyon.
Melody is a teeny Easter egg
that we don't pay off ever.
All the teeny little touches
are what makes it feel so real.
I think that's the fun part
kind of like trying
to evolve the sets to match
like what you guys are up to.
Want to go in here?
This is crazy right?
I don't feel like it's real.
So I mean we changed the layout
in here too last season.
Like four was like
a big transition
so the bed was in this corner
for the first three seasons.
This color of this room
is crazy.
But yeah it's Guava
if anybody wants to know.
It's Guava.
Watermelon and the-
It's very guava.
Yeah wait this is the thing
in my actual apartment
that I had with markers
just like this.
And this is like
the recreation of your chair.
Yeah so this is crazy.
First the pilot
we brough in my chair,
like all this stuff and then
they recreated this chair
that's like a very mid century
retro-y vibe.
It looks so good. Like this
is not a chair that exists.
And I might cry right now,
but literally you two
have like made the show.
Like you have made the tone
of the look of every space
that we've entered people
like want our stuff
and they copy our shit
and it feels real
and you have made
the characters feel
so fully fleshed out and honest
and like they actually live
in New York City
and so thank you guys.
Really.
I'm gonna cry too.
For putting your whole selves
into this really.
It's been a (laughs)